devant une crise sans précédent des
mesures exceptionnelles gouvernement
fédéral évoque la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence selon lui l'urgence est
national la situation intenable on
n'accepte pas que les gens viennent
endommager notre économie et faire mal
et brimer les libertés de leurs
concitoyens par des manifestations
illégales postes frontières bloqué au
manitoba saisie d'armes en alberta
pendant qu'à ottawa les manifestants
prennent leurs aises après 18 jours
d'occupation le gouvernement n'entend
pas déployé l'armée mais octroie aux
policiers des pouvoirs exceptionnels
protéger les infrastructures
essentielles comme les aéroports et les
postes frontière et imposer les amende
maximale de 5000 $ et des peines jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison ottawa s'attaque
aussi aux financements étrangers les
compagnies de sociaux financement
devront rapporter aux autorités les dons
douteux et les institutions financières
pourront geler des comptes en banque
sans préavis vive crastes à voulions le
gouvernement vise directement le gagne
pain des manifestants récalcitrants
c'est votre cas mais on est utilisé dans
ces blocages vos comptes d'entreprises
seront gelés
l'assurance de votre véhicule sera
suspendu l'ontario la province la plus
touchée appuie l'initiative fédérale et
game over the hot one should have mais
d'autres premier ministre s'oppose aux
mesures d'urgence fédérale qu'il juge
superflu au québec on n'a pas ces
problèmes là puis deuxièmement faut être
prudent actuellement ce pro pres pôle de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu ce soin
d'associer
les organisateurs de l'occupation disent
qu'ils ne sont pas intimidés et ils
serrent les rangs nos matchs il des eaux
à ottawa l'opposition conservatrice et
mais des préoccupations la décision qui
a été prise aujourd'hui par le premier
ministre risque d'envenimer la situation
plutôt que d'apaiser les tensions les
mesures d'urgence entre en vigueur
immédiatement
mais les parlementaires auront un droit
de regard
il en débattrons aux communes et au
sénat d'ici sept jours le contenu ne
peut pas durer sergent il ne peut pas
avoir des chèques en blanc à la fois
extrême ou et il est premier ministre
depuis deux semaines pourquoi on est
seulement il a seulement décidé d'agir
maintenant justin trudeau assure ne pas
prendre cette décision historique à la
légère le gouvernement est conscient de
créer un précédent en déclarant
l'urgence nationale contre des
manifestants mais pour l'opposition le
seul fait de prendre ces mesures
exceptionnelles est un aveu d'échec il
sait que c'est noël radio canada ottawa